Let us now look at a different problem, not a 2 by 1 matrix problem but
a problem called the guards and
prisoners problem. Actually this problem goes by many names, Cannibals and
missionaries problem, the jealous husbands problem and so on. It was first seen
in a math text book about 880 and has been used by many people in AI for
discussing problem representation. Imagine that there are three guards and
three prisoners, on one bank of the river and they must all cross to
the other bank. There is one boat, just one boat and they can only take one or
two people at a time, not more and the boat cannot travel alone.
On either bank, prisoners can never outnumber the guards, if they do they will
overpower the guards. So, the number of guards must at least be equal to
the number of prisoners on each bank. We'll assume these are good prisoners.
They won't runaway if they're left alone. Although they might beat up
the guards if they outnumber them. That's the beauty of this class.
We lead with real problems, practical problems. We also make up problems to
help illustrate specific things. I think you're going to have fun with this one.